México lindo y querido, vive sus últimos
meses bajo el mando de Andrés Manuel López
Obrador.
Con mucha diferencia, uno de los perfiles
políticos más rupturistas que ha pasado
por la jefatura del Estado azteca.
Es hora, por tanto, de empezar a evaluar.
Y lo primero de todo es recordar que el líder
de MORENA, el Movimiento Regeneración Nacional,
prometía impulsar una enorme transformación
del país.
Esto incluía, por supuesto, una estrategia
de Seguridad Nacional, completamente nueva.
Al fin y al cabo la seguridad, o mejor dicho,
la falta de seguridad es uno de los grandes
problemas de México, si no el más importante
de todos.
N1(23 de marzo de 2017: López Obrador choca
con el Ejército mexicano en su camino a las
presidenciales de 2018.
El político ha subrayado desde hace un mes
las violaciones de derechos humanos cometidas
por los militares en el combate al narcotráfico.
El País)
N2(7 de diciembre de 2017: La polémica por
la propuesta de "amnistía" a criminales en
México del precandidato presidencial López
Obrador.
Durante la última década, López Obrador
ha criticado la estrategia de combate al crimen
organizado a través del despliegue del Ejército
y la Marina en las calles, sustituyendo a
las fuerzas civiles policiales.
BBC)
Sin embargo, al final parece que México cambió
a AMLO, más de lo que AMLO cambió a México.
Al menos en materia de seguridad.
N3(21 de julio de 2021: AMLO anuncia 50,000
millones de pesos adicionales para la Guardia
Nacional.
El Financiero)
N4(12 de agosto de 2022: AMLO buscará que
Ejército y Marina realicen labores permanentes
de seguridad pública para abatir la inseguridad.
InfoBae)
La pregunta es, ¿Es en este campo muy diferente
el México que deja López Obrador del que
recibió en 2018?
Pues, lo cierto es que sí, pero de forma
muy diferente a lo que podríamos imaginarnos
y a lo que prometió el propio AMLO.
Porque lo cierto es que en los últimos años
el gobierno mexicano ha ampliado exponencialmente
el rol de las fuerzas armadas.
Los militares tienen ahora a su cargo un montón
de cometidos: desde gestionar la seguridad
interior, hasta administrar aeropuertos, obras
e, incluso, empresas del estado.
Y eso, queridos amigos, ha hecho que en VisualPolitik
nos hagamos unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cómo demonios se explica que los militares
hayan ganado tanto peso con un presidente
que supuestamente quería desmilitarizar el
país?
¿Qué provocó semejante metamorfosis político?
¿Hasta qué punto deja AMLO un país militarizado?
Pues bien…
Manos a la obra, vamos con ello.
Pero antes, ¿te has parado a pensar en lo
que te estás perdiendo por no usar Surfshark?
Lo primero de todo, y más importante, es
la seguridad en la red.
Con Surfshark, tu actividad online está fuertemente
protegida, cifrada y a salvo de ojos curiosos.
Además, con CleanWeb, te despides de los
anuncios y el malware.
¿Y qué pasa con los emails?
Con Surfshark Alert te enterarás al instante
si alguien ha intentado filtrar tu información.
Pero, ¡aún hay más!
Surfshark es la primera VPN comercial con
servidores en más de un centenar de países.
Vamos, algo así como un pasaporte global
a golpe de click: podrás acceder a cualquier
contenido bloqueado por ubicación.
Y si te preocupa tener que elegir en qué
dispositivo usarlo, tranquilo.
Con la misma cuenta, puedes proteger todos
tus dispositivos, ya sea tu móvil, tu tablet,
la tele o el ordenador.
Esto hace que puedas compartir la cuenta con
tus amigos, por ejemplo.
Así, entre todos, cada uno pagaréis unos
pocos céntimos al mes.
Además por ser parte de la comunidad VisualPolitik
podrás disfrutar de 3 meses extra totalmente
gratis usando el código “POLITIK”.
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos con nuestro video
de hoy!
Fuera de México no es muy conocido, pero
las fuerzas armadas de este país tienen una
historia única en América Latina: haberse
enfrentado con todas las grandes potencias
occidentales.
Estamos, por supuesto, hablando de la guerra
que libraron México y Estados Unidos entre
los años 1846 y 1848.
Y también a la intervención militar de Francia
en México entre 1862 y 1867, un conflicto
en el que tanto el Reino Unido como España
se sumaron a las fuerzas francesas.
Con todo, a principios del siglo XX, los principales
problemas eran ya internos.
El ocaso del dictador Porfirio Díaz sumergió
a las fuerzas armadas en un caos de idas y
venidas que duró hasta la revolución mexicana
allá por la década de los años 20.
A partir de entonces, los uniformados mexicanos
sirvieron como fieles guardianes de la Constitución,
lo que durante décadas fue prácticamente
equivalente a estar a las órdenes del PRI,
el partido que gobernó México de forma ininterrumpida
durante más de 70 años.
En cualquier caso, lo importante, es que esta
tradición constitucional caló hondo entre
los uniformados.
Además, durante el siglo XX México evitó
cualquier aventura militarista, por lo que
a diferencia de lo que ocurrió en América
Latina, las fuerzas armadas mexicanas no intervinieron
en asuntos de estado.
Es decir, aquí no hubo golpes ni generales
emocionados con la idea de imponer la bota
militar coEmo sistema político.
Quizás eso explica por qué las fuerzas armadas
se han convertido en la institución que mayor
confianza despierta entre los mexicanos
Sea como sea, ahora el gobierno de AMLO le
ha dado un giro de 180 grados al rol de las
Fuerzas Armadas en los asuntos de Estado.
AMLO les ha metido de lleno en espacios que
hasta ahora han sido tradicionalmente civiles.
Hablamos de campos tan poco castrenses como
estos:
N5(22 sep, 2022: Dan luz verde a nueva empresa
militar para administrar complejo turístico
en Islas Marías.
Forbes)
N6(14 abr, 2023: AMLO entregará al Ejército
el control de las aduanas en la frontera.
InfoBae)
N7(10 ago, 2023: El gobierno de López Obrador
compró Mexicana de Aviación: la manejará
el Ejército y tendrá pasajes low-cost.
La Nación)
Ahora los mexicanos están viendo cómo de
repente los oficiales de las fuerzas armadas
empiezan a encargarse de la gestión de empresas
turísticas, agencias de telecomunicaciones
o, incluso, el control de la infraestructura
energética.
Esto es lo que se ha venido a conocer como
la militarización de México.
El peso de las fuerzas armadas en el gobierno
y en el día a día es cada vez mayor.
Y la pregunta es: ¿hasta qué punto los uniformados
están cómodos con este nuevo rol?
¿Hasta dónde llega su nueva influencia?
¿Puede el camuflaje verde oliva provocar
un cambio de paradigma en el sistema político
azteca?
¿Por qué AMLO está apostando todo a una
institución que hasta hace poco rechazaba?
Queridos amigos, amigas, como siempre en este
vídeo, vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas.
Vamos con ello.
T1(LA GUERRA CONTRA EL NARCO)
No es un secreto, México tiene un problema
por encima de todos los demás: el narcotráfico.
Un problema tan grande que frecuentemente
llega a sobrepasar las capacidades convencionales
de las fuerzas de seguridad.
Eso al menos es lo que pensó el presidente
Felipe Calderón cuando en 2006 le declaró
la guerra a los narcos.
(Como he subrayado, hoy el crimen organizado
representa la mayor amenaza para la seguridad,
la libertad y la tranquilidad de los mexicanos.
Es un enemigo que no conoce límites.)
De esta forma, a partir de finales del 2006,
el gobierno mexicano comenzó a emplear progresivamente
a efectivos del ejército para apoyar a la
policía en operativos contra los cárteles.
Poco a poco la asistencia militar se fue haciendo
cada vez más común hasta que prácticamente
se convirtió en el operativo habitual.
Entonces los territorios que lograban ser
“asegurados” permanecían bajo control
militar.
Asimismo, en paralelo, se comenzaron a crear
grupos de autodefensa, también conocidos
como las “guardias comunitarias”.
Estos grupos estaban compuestos por familias
agrarias que se armaban para poder defenderse
de los narcos.
¿Y sabéis qué ocurrió entonces?
Que los cárteles también empezaron a armarse
hasta los dientes, y ese fue el comienzo de
una terrible pesadilla.
N8(13 sep, 2008: Hallados en México 24 jóvenes
rematados a tiros.
El País)
N9(8 sep, 2010: Hallan muertos a dos investigadores
de la matanza de 72 inmigrantes.
El Mundo)
N10(30 ago, 2011: México arresta a cinco
Zetas por la masacre de 52 personas en el
casino de Monterrey.
El Mundo)
N11(30 ene, 2012: ​​Los narcos asesinan
en México a once músicos de una banda de
cumbia.
Clarin)
N12(17 sep 2015: Detuvieron en México al
narco que habría ordenado incinerar a los
43 estudiantes.
InfoBae)
Y estos son tan solo unos pocos ejemplos de
decenas y decenas de casos diferentes.
Terrible.
Al final la guerra contra el narco terminó
con un colosal fracaso.
Cuando caía un cártel rápidamente surgía
otro mientras la violencia se multiplicaba.
Con todo, ni Calderón, ni tampoco su sucesor,
Enrique Peña Nieto, se atrevieron a modificar
a gran escala el rol de las fuerzas armadas
en la seguridad interior.
Nadie quería dar muestras de debilidad.
Nadie, excepto un candidato: Andrés Manuel
López Obrador, que en 2012 decía cosas como
estas:
(Tenemos que ir sacando al Ejército de las
calles.
El Ejército no está preparado para esta
función, es otro su encargo, es defender
la soberanía nacional y no debe de seguirse
exponiendo al Ejército)
Y ahí no quedó todo.
Más tarde, en la campaña de 2018, AMLO intensificó
y amplió sus críticas.
Por aquella época, además, surgieron varios
casos de abuso de autoridad e, incluso, ejecuciones
extra sumarias en el marco de la Guerra contra
el Narco.
(Por si fuera poco, Genaro García Luna, que
fue secretario de Seguridad Pública durante
el sexenio de Felipe Calderón, y Salvador
Cienfuegos, extitular de la Secretaría de
la Defensa Nacional durante el gobierno de
Enrique Peña Nieto, estaban hasta el cuello
de denuncias de corrupción, sobornos, trapicheos
con los carteles y lavado de dinero.
La guerra contra el narco había entrado en
una vía muerta y AMLO supo sacar rédito
electoral de ello.)
MORENA, el Movimiento Regeneración Nacional,
arrasó en aquellos comicios de 2018 y se
llevó algo más del 53% de los votos.
Y no solo logró la presidencia, también
la mayoría parlamentaria para el bloque oficialista.
En otras palabras, el gobierno estaba completamente
en sus manos para poder cumplir su programa
político.
Sin embargo, con las Fuerzas Armadas, optó
por otro camino completamente diferente.
T2(DE REGAÑADOS A CONSENTIDOS)
AMLO prometió sacar al ejército de las calles,
pero en cuanto llegó al poder hizo exactamente
lo contrario.
López Obrador se convirtió en presidente
de México el día 1 de diciembre de 2018.
Pues bien, tan solo durante sus dos primeros
años al frente del gobierno mexicano militarizó
prácticamente la misma cantidad de funciones
que el resto de gobiernos durante toda la
década anterior.
Fijaos.
La mayor parte de tareas y competencias traspasadas
a los militares tienen que ver con la gestión
de las obras públicas o el medio ambiente.
Sin ir más lejos, hace poco, aquí en VisualPolitik
os hablamos del Tren Maya.
Lo hicimos en un vídeo que montamos en colaboración
con Harvard International Review, ¿os acordáis?
Pues como os dijimos, el Tren Maya también
tiene al frente a los militares.
Son ellos quienes están pilotando su construcción.
Con todo, incluso a pesar de esta apuesta,
el gobierno de AMLO sí mantuvo alguna de
sus promesas de campaña respecto a las fuerzas
armadas y la seguridad.
Al menos, lo hizo durante algún tiempo.
(No se han detenido a capos porque no es esa
nuestra función principal)
(No se puede enfrentar el mal con el mal,
y estamos convencidos que fue un error, un
crimen el haber declarado la guerra a la delincuencia
al inicio del gobierno de Calderón)
Pese a todo, desde la llegada de AMLO al poder
el presupuesto de las Fuerzas Armadas también
se ha disparado, aunque claro, esto tiene
trampa, porque también han asumido muchos
más roles.
Es decir, que su peso en el presupuesto público
ha crecido y mucho, aun cuando la mejora en
las funciones estrictamente propias de las
fuerzas armadas ha sido mucho más limitada.
Pero, más presupuesto, nuevas funciones,
los militares empiezan a ser omnipresentes
en la administración mexicana.
Están por todas partes.
Y la pregunta es, ¿por qué AMLO cambió
tanto de opinión?
Pues al parecer este fue básicamente el motivo,
fijaos;
C1("AMLO expuso entonces su doble plan para
combatir ambos problemas.
En primer lugar, dijo, quiere dar a los militares
más poder y autoridad en las operaciones
antinarcóticos porque es el menos corrupto
de todos los organismos de México y puede
ser el más eficaz.
Señaló, sin embargo, que para ello sería
necesaria una reforma constitucional, pero
se mostró convencido de que podría conseguirlo."
Wikileaks, Charla filtrada entre funcionarios
de la Embajada de EE.UU. en México y AMLO
- Enero de 2006)
Es decir, que AMLO confiaba en que los militares
fueran menos corruptos y, por tanto, más
eficaces.
De esta forma, cuanto menos cosas queden en
manos de los civiles, mejor que mejor.
Y eso es lo que explica que a finales de 2022
anunciara una de sus medidas más chocantes.
Fijaos.
N13(9 sept, 2022: Congreso México aprueba
que Guardia Nacional pase a control militar
en medio de críticas.
InfoBae)
¿Y qué tiene esto de particular?
Os preguntaréis.
Pues que la Guardia Nacional fue creada por
el propio AMLO en 2019 con la idea de que
fuese un cuerpo civil y no militar.
Era la forma de sacar al ejército de la seguridad
en las calles.
Sin embargo, en 2022 tuvo que recular, ¡y
de qué manera!
Acabó entregándole su juguete favorito,
la recién creada Guardia Nacional, a los
militares.
La evolución de la criminalidad y la violencia
fue tan mala, que no le quedó otra.
(La gente en nuestro país le tiene confianza
al ejército y le tiene confianza a la Secretaría
de Marina y le tiene confianza a la guardia
nacional)
De hecho, este no fue su único cambio de
opinión ni mucho menos.
AMLO siempre consideró un error la guerra
contra el narcotráfico, ahora, sin embargo,
tiene una opinión bastante diferente,
(Si cambie de opinión ya viendo el problema
que me heredaron como enfrentar el problema
de la seguridad)
Está bien cambiar de opinión cuando uno
se equivoca.
No pasa nada.
No lo estamos reprobando ni mucho menos.
El problema es que tampoco está claro que
esta estrategia esté funcionado.
O bueno, qué diantres, es que no está funcionando.
Solo tenemos que echar un vistazo a la gráfica
de homicidios para darnos cuenta de que esto
no carbura bien.
Fijaos.
C2(“Casi dos décadas de intervención militar
en seguridad pública no han logrado poner
fin a la violencia implacable de los cárteles
mexicanos y han propiciado innumerables atrocidades
cometidas por soldados y marinos, con casi
total impunidad”.
Tyler Mattiace, investigador para México
de Human Rights Watch)
Hoy México no solo está atravesando una
de sus etapas más violentas, sino que además
nunca antes las fuerzas armadas habían tenido
tanto protagonismo.
Ahora bien, en esta ocasión nuestra intención
no es centrarnos en la seguridad.
Lo que nos importa en esta ocasión es ver
cómo AMLO ha entrado en una sorprendente
carrera para “militarizar” el país a
toda velocidad.
Y eso, eso queridos amigos, es algo que trae
consigo algunos problemas.
¿Queréis saber de qué estamos hablando?
Pues vamos con ello.
T3(LAS TRES SOMBRAS DE LA MILITARIZACIÓN
MEXICANA)
Por regla general, la militarización de funciones
y competencias públicas que vayan más allá
del mundo castrense no suele dar buen resultado.
Básicamente, porque los militares tienen
una especialización muy particular.
Aunque es verdad, el caso de México es muy
particular: la corrupción, la violencia,
la falta de confianza en las instituciones
civiles…
En cualquier caso, el proceso de militarización
que está sacando adelante AMLO plantea algunas
dudas y algunos problemas.
Por ejemplo, en primer lugar, el gobierno
mexicano le está dando a las Fuerzas Armadas
voluminosas partidas presupuestarias para
construir obras públicas, gestionar aeropuertos
o encargarse de campañas de publicidad para
centros turísticos.
El problema es que esto reduce la capacidad
de control y fiscalización de todos esos
fondos.
¿Por qué?
Pues, exactamente por esto:
C3(“Las FFAA recurren sistemáticamente
a clasificar y resguardar la información
de sus dependencias bajo el argumento de que
no se comprometa la seguridad nacional, la
seguridad pública o la defensa nacional (…) rastrear
y evaluar el uso de los recursos públicos
se vuelve sumamente complicado”
El negocio de la militarización en México
- México Unido Contra la Delincuencia (septiembre
2022)
Es lo que vimos que estaba pasando con el
Tren Maya.
Cada vez son más los contratos que los militares
asignan de manera bastante discrecional, con
poca o ninguna transparencia y sin cumplir
todos los requisitos legales de las licitaciones
públicas.
Ya sabéis, el argumento es siempre el mismo:
seguridad nacional.
En segundo lugar, el razonamiento de establecer
administraciones militares para revertir la
corrupción en los espacios civiles puede
terminar generando algo así como una lógica
de profecía autocumplida.
Si hay menos civiles y más militares, a corto
plazo es posible que la corrupción caiga.
Pero, claro, con menos transparencia, más
atribuciones y profesionales menos cualificados,
Primera pregunta: ¿por qué no va a terminar
apareciendo también aquí la corrupción?
Segunda, ¿acaso la solución va a ser militarizar
por completo el estado?
Esto cuanto menos genera dudas.
Y en tercer lugar, tenemos el que quizás
es el mayor problema de todos: la temida pérdida
de la neutralidad.
C4(“El intento de que la delegación a las
fuerzas armadas amarre las manos a futuros
gobiernos, también implica una mayor partidización
de las Fuerzas Armadas, su progresiva identificación
con un proyecto político específico.
Y algo más serio: implica la pérdida de
neutralidad, una característica esencial
para las instituciones que cumplen tareas
de estado y que las Fuerzas Armadas en México
por décadas lograron mantener” Militarización
y estado de derecho en México: Hacia un callejón
sin salida – Juan Ríos Figueroa (Fellow
del Wilson Center)
AMLO está convirtiendo a los militares, o
al menos a sus altos mandos, en auténticos
políticos.
Y eso puede llegar a ser un problema muy importante.
¿Aceptarían los militares a un gobierno
que cuestione su trabajo?
¿No tendrán acaso preferencia por aquellos
líderes políticos que les prometan más
influencia, poder y presupuesto?
Y si son más honestos, como dice AMLO, para
administrar puertos y obras públicas, ¿Por
qué no lo serían directamente para gobernar?
Ojo, que la historia nos enseña que tenemos
que preocuparnos de estas cosas.
En cualquier caso, desde abril de este 2023,
la Corte Suprema ha comenzado a cuestionar
todo este crecimiento sin freno de los roles
de las FFAA en el gobierno.
De momento la pugna de la corte con AMLO no
tiene un desenlace claro.
Sea como sea, lo que podemos tener claro es
que la militarización de México ya no es
un proyecto, sino una realidad.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para ti:
¿Qué te parece que los militares asuman
cada vez más funciones?
¿Te parece una buena respuesta a la corrupción?
¿Estás a favor o en contra?
¿De qué otra forma se pueden solventar los
graves problemas de corrupción, crimen y
narcotráfico que atraviesa México?
Al fin y al cabo, sin ellos, es muy probable
que México se convertiría en un país muy
próspero.
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios.
Y recordad, con el código “POLITIK” acabado
en “K” podréis disfrutar de 3 meses extra
totalmente gratis con Surfshark.
El link, como siempre, en la descripción.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.